speaking of pretending to be things
you're not Jimmy Fallon you know Jimmy
Fallon host of The Tonight Show formerly
on Saturday Night Live Jimmy Fallon is
coming out and finally apologizing for a
joke he told 20 years ago I kid you not
Jimmy Fallon started trending on Twitter
yesterday or the day before because a
sketch resurfaced in which Jimmy Fallon
did an impression of Chris Rock and when
Jimmy Fallon did the impression of Chris
Rock he darkened his skin and so this
was portrayed as Jimmy Fallon engaging
in blackface which many of his
colleagues have done but they don't get
in trouble for it for some reason we'll
get to that in a moment
and so Jimmy Fallon had to apologize
here's the sketch now we're talking
guess what not a lot of black folks on
the show right a lot of black folks on
the show know what cuz black folks don't
like the answer question oh they want to
be booed ass
we gotta ask that kind of questions like
imagine anyone how many grams of crack
did Rick James mostly recorded super
fresh
Frieda's do you think the only way to
get a brother on the show the name it
who loves $50 cash and a pair of poopit
okay so first of all first take away
from this it's a pretty good Chris Rock
impression right it is it sounds a lot
like Chris Rock second take away Jimmy
Fallon's not doing blackface he darkened
his skin his face looks black that's not
what black faces okay there are other
left-wing comedians who have done
blackface in this way who don't get in
trouble for it Jimmy Kimmel did he
portrayed Karl Malone and darkened his
skin and put made his face look black
that too not blackface or Robert Downey
jr. the actor he portrayed a white guy
playing a black guy in a movie Tropic
Thunder also not blackface what's the
distinction blackface and the reason
that people are offended by blackface is
when white actors darken their skin to
mock black people that is considered
offensive and it actually has a long
history in the American theatrical
tradition but putting all that aside and
saying obviously nobody's gonna do that
anymore
that is what blackface is doing an
impression of Chris Rock is not doing
blackface because Jimmy Fallon is not
mocking black people generally he is
doing a actually very good precise
impression of Chris Rock same thing with
Jimmy Kimmel as Carl Malone
same thing with Robert Downey jr. Robert
Downey jr. is not doing blackface he's
doing a white guy wearing blackface to
show the absurdity of blackface in that
movie Tropic Thunder not the same thing
and yet Jimmy Fallon apologized he goes
in 2000 while on SNL I made a terrible
decision to do an impersonation of Chris
Rock while in blackface there is no
excuse for this I'm very sorry for
making this unquestionably offensive
decision and thank you all for holding
me accountable oh my goodness gracious
that is so pathetic I get it Jimmy
Fallon just wants to be a nice guy on TV
and be liked by everybody and so he's
going to apologize for these kind of
things
Jay Leno was a little bit like that you
know Fallon's predecessor social justice
warriors here are apoplectic with this
this sort of fake problem I don't Chris
Rock is not offended by this I don't
think most black people are offended by
this I think it's mostly I'm just
looking at the commentary on it I think
it's mostly white liberals who were
offended by this because it's always
white liberals being offended on other
people's behalf they go after Jimmy
Fallon because he's a little bit of an
easy target he's not as left-wing as say
a Jimmy Kimmel so Jimmy Kimmel generally
gets away with it
you know they kick megyn kelly off of
NBC for even mentioning blackface she
mentioned it but Joy Behar who is also
employed by network television totally
fine who she actually wore black
blackface she did she wore a costume as
I think Diana Ross same kind of issue
we're talking about here we did a show a
week or two ago saying that we we have
too few problems in this country this
would be one of them but but actually
this this itself is the problem which is
weaponizing this kind of performed
offended 'no stew
take out people that you don't like even
even when this has not been an issue for
20 years even when it's you know in some
ways it's like during a political
campaign
when assault allegations come up race
racial allegations kind of what whatever
kind of allegations come up you say wait
a second no one's heard about this for
30 years now all of a sudden it pops up
it seems a little bit convenient same
thing here as well
[Music]
[Music]